el precio de la energía además es
coyuntural mente es un juego por
precisamente el tema de la guerra entre
ucrania y rusia porque pues como lo
sabemos rusia es un gran proveedor para
la unión europea de gases entonces otro
de los temas en la campaña que ha sido
en juego ha sido cómo repartir mejor la
energía para que no todo recae sobre
algún
algún material o algún algún tipo de
energía en específico pues aquí no somos
economistas pero efectivamente se podría
decir que a través de los subsidios y de
las ayudas se podría eventualmente
ayudar a que los franceses puedan tener
acceso a la energía sin embargo hay algo
que quisiera añadir aquí que es bien
importante es bien delicado jugar sobre
la fiscalía de esos productos
energéticos porque porque la energía es
un bien escaso y si no mostramos a los
habitantes de un país francia n en este
caso un señal precio es decir si lo si
no lo sé si lo mantenemos bajo de manera
artificial los francés van a consumir
más y eso es un error porque tampoco un
estado podría subsidiar de manera
indiscriminada a toda una población
sobre el l la energía entonces a través
de subsidios sería quizás de mi modo de
ver la mejor forma pero sin bajar la
fiscalidad